notre invité politique c'est donc
Guillaume Lacroix bonjour vous êtes le
président du Parti radical de gauche
nous sommes ensemble pendant une
vingtaine de minutes et on va parler
notamment de votre future liste au
élections européennes cette interview
elle est comme chaque jour en
partenariat avec la presse régionale qui
est aujourd'hui représenté par Fabrice
vesser Redon bonjour Fabrice vous êtes
rédacteur en chef au groupebra donc les
journaux de l'Est de la France Guillaume
Lacroix d'abord une réaction à la
disparition de Gérard Colomb on l'a pris
ce weekend l'ancien maire de Lyon
l'ancien ministre de l'Intérieur
qu'est-ce que vous vous retenez de ce
parcours politique difficile de de
résumer le parcours politique de Gérard
Colomb rapidement évidemment comme je
crois tous les habitants d'ovne Ronald
tous ceux qui l'ont aussi croisé nous
sommes pas de la même génération
politique mais fa de la la politique
dans la même région c'est forcément
croisé Gérard colon émotion tristesse et
puis peut-être la une du progrès d'hier
le Lyon est mort qui est je pense le
parfait résumé de cet homme qui
incarnait sa ville qu' l'aimait c'est
indéniable qui l'a transformé
profondément et puis de cet homme
atypique cette voix inimitable ce style
direct cette capacité à ne pas envoyer
dire ce qu'on a à dire et et et à posé
des actes politiques alors on a parfois
été en accord je sa combien il a été
côté de Thierry Brard par exemple au
moment de l'élection législative Thierry
bryard qui était député PRG et puis
ministre des Sports je sais aussi les
choix politiques qu'il a fait ensuite
c'était un homme libre et oui justement
sur le fond c'était un homme de centre
gauche qui finalement partagait les
mêmes valeurs que vous est-ce que il a
eu raison à la fin de son parcours
politique de faire ce mariage entre le
centre gauche le centre droit autour
d'Emmanuel Macron il a essayé cette voix
politique le il l'a quitté aussi
euh pas forcément dans dans le même état
d'esprit qu'il y était rentré parce que
le en même temps a ses limites et et que
si Gérard colon a plutôt été cet homme
du en même temps et puis pour être maire
de Lyon il faut plutôt être un homme en
capacité de compromis de conciliation
entre des pensées différentes il
n'empêche qu'à la fin les choses se sont
quand même un peu crispées avec la
majorité au moment où en même temps
était basculé peut-être plus d'un côté
que de l'autre il a été Gérard coland a
été chassé de son fauteuil de mer par
les écologistes est-ce que avec du recul
vous diriez qu'il a raté un rendez-vous
avec les questions environnementales et
globalement avec ses part tonnerire de
gauche non je ne pense pas je pense
qu'il a cultivé jusqu'au bout sa liberté
de ton sa liberté d'esprit je crois
qu'il il a quand même donné à Lyon un
rayonnement extraordinaire que chacun
reconnaît aujourd'hui et donc par
principe c'était un homme qui allait de
l'avant parfois quand on va de l'avant
on n'est pas compris dans son temps en
2018 quand il quitte le ministère de
l'Intérieur au moment de la passession
de pouvoir avec et bien Édouard Philippe
il a eu cette phrase ce constat sur la
fracturation du pays je le cite
aujourd'hui nous vivons côte à côte
demain je crains que nous vivions face-
à faceace est-ce qu'il a été visionnaire
quand on voit ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui dans notre pays et pas plus
tard que ce weekend avec les événements
de roman sur iser ou j'allais vous dire
il suffit de regarder ce qui se passe
dans la Drome pour comprendre le niveau
destension qui existe dans notre pays le
niveau de fracture aussi comprendre que
partout la violence émerge depuis des
années mais qu'elle devient aujourd'hui
une forme d'expression systématique que
la violence devient le nouveau mode de
rapports sociaux ce qui est extrêmement
inquiétant insupportable quand ça
conduit évidemment à la mort de Thomas
ça devient ingérable ça devient immonde
quand ça conduit au aux exactions de
l'extrême droite à Roman ce weekend
c'est encore plus insupportable parce
que on n'en finit pas de faire monter la
violence et quand je vois monsieur sioti
avoir la ratonade tolérante pour ne pas
dire bienveillante je me dis qu'il y a
aussi un accompagnement de certains
responsables politiques et aujourd'hui
terriblement sur tout l'arc de l'extrême
gauche à l'extrême droite qui ne compte
que sur les violence pour remplacer le
débat public c'est extrêmement
inquiétant sur la concorde civile et sur
l'esprit républicain qui devrait régner
dans notre pays surtout au moment où
notre pays pleure un jeune homme
assassiné dans une soirée dans la Drome
alors on va parler des élections
européennes puisque samedi à Paris vous
avez annoncé que le Parti radical de
gauche allait présenter une liste aux
élections européennes une liste que vous
mèneriez ce serait la 5e liste de gauche
après celle du Parti socialiste des
écologistes des insoumis des communistes
pourquoi encore aggraver la division de
la gauche ah ben d'abord ce sera pas du
tout une division puisque c'est la seule
liste
hornupes je note que la balcanisation de
la gauche c'est dans la nupess c'est
leur affaire or nupess je ne connais à
ce stade qu'une seule liste celle que
nous nous proposons de présenter ensuite
je sais bien que les procès en division
viennent toujours mais je préfère les
procès en division que les procès en
compromission et il se trouve que ma
famille politique depuis l'origine n'a
pas souhaité aller dans laanupes parce
qu'elle ne souhaitait pas se soumettre
au projet politique des insoumis et
encore moins à l'infamie d'un certain
nombre de leurs responsables depuis les
dernières semaines qui est-ce qui
pourrait composer cette liste aux
élections européennes nous avons dit
d'entrer de jeu que le sujet aujourd'hui
c'était effectivement au moment où notre
pays connaît des tensions inouï au
moment où la violence s'exprime partout
au moment où la violence s'exprime
autour de nous nous sommes dans un
contexte international extrêmement
inquiétant au moment où les défis aussi
auquels nous sommes confrontés je pense
au réchauffement climatique je pense au
défis y compris économique dans ce
moment-là on peut pas vraiment se
permettre de vouloir jouer la bannière
d'abord il faut d'abord jouer le
rassemblement l'ouverture la capacité
surtout à apporter des réponses
cohérentes aux peur aux colères et donc
nous allons ouvrir notre listre à toutes
celles et ceux qui sont orphelins de
cette gauche républicaine laïque
proeuropéenne toutes celles et ceux qui
étaient déçus du macronisme jusqu'à
gluxman jusque aux écologistes de jadou
veulent faire une liste cohérente
politiquement pour répondre au problème
des Français le nom de Bernard casdu
circule beaucoup il pourrait accompagner
cette liste Bernard casenu a créé la
convention dans laquelle nous l'avons
rejoint pour faire le rassemblement
Bernard casenu est un homme qui prône le
rassemblement de la gauche cohérente
depuis des mois et des mois donc cas
reste sur cette ligne politique qui est
la sienne par ailleurs la convention
n'est pas un parti politique oui mais
pour ces élections européennes cas est
un homme d'État je ne pense pas que son
rôle soit aujourd'hui d'être vraiment
impliqué dans ce moment de construction
des listes politiques il dira ce qu'il a
à dire il a commencé à le dire chez nous
samedi en disant qu'il prenait le
rassemblement il dira dans les semaines
qui viennent comment il voit évoluer la
situation c'est sa parole na jamais été
question qu'il en soit la tête non
est-ce qu'il vous a dit qu'il allait
s'engager dans la campagne à vos côtés
il a dit que il s'engageraient pour le
rassemblement charge maintenant à celles
et ceux à gauche et donc au premier r
desquel le Parti radical de gauche qui
est quand même le seul parti qui propose
le rassemblement moi je ne note que des
partis qui proposent d'être entre eux
enfermés dans leurs officines qui ont
toutes échoué alors que nous sommes les
seuls à dire que finalement au regarde
de la situation le sujet c'est pas
tellement le drapeau du parti le sujet
c'est véritablement la patrie vous dites
que vous êtes la seule liste hornupè le
Parti socialiste a suspendu a décidé
d'un moratoire de sa participation à
cette union de la gauche de la nuupess
autour de la France insoumise pourquoi
ne pas faire une liste commune avec les
socialistes et parce que moi je ne crois
pas que la politique ce soit des
moratoires quand vous êtes confronté à
l'infamie de ce qui a été dit par un
grand nombre de parlementaires et les
filles suite aux événement dramatique et
tragique et horrible du 7 octobre quand
vous êtes dans une dans un moment
politique où il faut montrer une fermeté
républicaine à toute épreuve et en même
temps évidemment une bienveillance
humaniste de gauche pour aussi
accompagner les peurs et les colères et
bien dans ce moment-là vous ne vous
posez pas la question de savoir si LFI
est fréquentable ou ne l' pas LFI a un
projet politique qui ne correspond en
rien à ce qui est une gauche de
gouvernement ils ont un projet politique
ils ont des méthodes politiques aussi et
ces méthodes sont insupportables la
majorité du temps partir de là vous ne
vous posez pas la question de savoir si
vous allez attendre de voir si ça range
si ça améliore et cetera c'est bon
chacun a vu depuis maintenant 2 ans ce
qui les fit Guillaume Lacroix vous
pourriez travailler avec quelqu'un
d'autre que je méenchan à la tête je ne
veux pas faire du sujet le sujet
Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est trop facile je
ne peux pas travailler avec madame
auonau je ne peux pas travailler avec
Monsieur guot je ne peux pas travailler
avec un projet politique qui n'est pas
clairement républiquain je ne peux pas
travailler avec un projet politique qui
n'est pas clairement fondé sur j'allais
dire une forme d'expression public qui
soit respectueuse qui ne soit pas en
permanence en train de chercher et de
provoquer la violence si jamais les
socialistes décident de sortir de la
nupes vous leur tendez la main pour les
élections européennes mais évidemment
j'ai été de tous les combats avec les
socialistes pendant des années donc
c'est pas à moi qu'on va faire le procès
de l'hostilité par principe au Parti
socialiste simplement je le dis moi en
2019 je faisais la campagne de raphaë
gluxman au côté du Parti socialiste
depuis c'est pas moi qui a changé hein
depuis c'est eux c'est eux qui ont fait
d'autres choix politiques je leur laisse
faire c'est je les respecte mais je ne
les partage pas face à la situation
politique on ne reste pas dans
l'hypocrisie la laacheter d'un moratoire
on sait où on habite et on le dit aux
Français et aux Français vous savez dans
ce moment-là où les gens ne croient plus
dans nos partis politiques dans ce
moment-là où les gens croient plus
vraiment à la parole politique il ne
reste qu'une chose la clarté de la
sincérité donc soit vous êtes sincère et
clair et nous nous sommes cohérents au
PRG depuis des années en disant nous
n'irons pas nous soumettre au projet
insoumis parce que ça n'est pas le nôtre
il est contraire à notre histoire il est
contraire à notre philosophie politique
on est pour l'union de la gauche mais
moi je préfère la gauche plurielle à la
nupes les choses sont claires je préfère
l'équilibre des forces de gauche à la
domination par son extrême et un des
extrêmes qui est aujourd'hui dans des
postures qui sont inqualifiables et
pourquoi le PRG qui représente ce centre
gauche ne ferait pas list commune
notamment avec la majorité
présidentielle la liste de la majorité
présidentielle qui va rassembler des
proeuropéens ce sont les mots ce weekend
de Stéphane séjourné qui est pressenti
pour diriger cette liste parce que dans
partir aveal de gauche et gauche et donc
pour vous il y a il y a plus de gauche
au sein de la majorité présidentielle je
ne l'entends plus vous l'entendez plus
ben justement on va parler de l'avenir
de la gauche toujours sur le Parti
socialiste est-ce que selon vous ce
parti socialiste a encore un avenir
alors que par exemple Bernard casneuve
pense qu'Olivier fort sera je le cite le
dernier Premier secrétaire de ce parti
moi je ne suis pas socialiste je n'ai
jamais été je rentré au Parti radical de
gauche à 18 ans militant de base je suis
devenu président de ce parti je suis
fier d'appartenir à un parti qui permet
cette logique de mérite républicain qui
permet cette logique finalement de
construction autour des convictions ce
qui se passe au Parti socialiste les
regardent c'est leur histoire c'est leur
vie et ce sont vos alliés historiques ce
sont des alliés historiques mais je le
dis aussi dans ce moment-là au moment où
l'histoire politique sécrit chacun prend
ses responsabilités le PRG prend les
siennes il dit nous il faut une offre
politique cohérente républicaine laïque
pro-européenne il faut la faire avec
toutes celles et tous ceux qui partagent
ce point de vue je pense à Carole Delga
de la fusse je pense évidemment Nicolas
il y a plein de socialistes avec
lesquels je travaille et puis il y en a
qui ne travaillent plus avec nous et
dans ce cadre là il a le premier
secrétaire qui ne veut plus travailler
avec moi qui ne me donne aucun signe de
vie qui a décidé que globalement son
sujet c'était pas de travailler avec ce
camp là mais c'est son droit c'est son
choix mais moi j'ai pris mes
Responsabilis d'ailleurs quelle raison
vous donne je ne cherche pas je ne suis
pas PS globalement chacun prend ses
responsabilités finalement vous ne
croyez plus dans cette union de la
gauche large vous parlez de de gauche
pluriel enfin vous pensez qu'il il va y
avoir de gauchesréconcili quand je vous
parle de gauche pluriel moi je crois que
justement je crois en l'union de la
gauche je ne crois pas à la soumission à
la France insoumise je crois au fait que
la gauche a toujours été dans ce pays
construite par des partis avec des
sensibilités différentes on a besoin de
l'écologie des écologistes on a besoin
du discours social du Parti communiste
on a besoin du discours républicain
laïque du PRG et on a aussi besoin d'un
socialisme qui soit à nouveau un
socialisme de gouvernement qui ne
tergiverse pas entre des méthodes
inqualifiables de LFI et un projet
politique honnêtement auquel nous devons
opposer une autre réponse politique
est-ce que c'est irréconciliable je n'en
sais rien mais c'est irréconcilié et
aujourd'hui de toute façon dans ce
moment politique je ne le redis je ne
vois pas ce que je pourrais faire en
photo à côté de Monsieur guireot de
Madame auonau de Madame Panau enfin il
arrive un moment il faut savoir
simplement constater des désaccords
politiques majeur c'est ça la démocratie
c'est pas grave c'est pas grave à partir
du moment où on l'assume et on le dit et
au moins dans ce cas-là on est sincère
avec les électeurs et dans le fond ce
qui vous pose problème sans jeu de mot
c'est leur radicalité c'est leur
extrémisme moi je suis un radicalisé de
la République mon parti est est un parti
radicalisé de la République la
radicalité n'est pas un problème
François mitteran était aussi dans une
forme de radicalité quand il avait ses
discours au moment de l'expression de au
moment de l'élection de 81 c'est pas la
radicalité à gauche elle est presque
nécessaire pour faire changer
profondément la société parce que c'est
pour ça que nous sommes là sommes pas là
pour être les gestionnaires d' système
qui formidablement j'allais dire
accompagne les Françaises on sait bien
aujourd'hui que notre pays est fracturé
d'injustice et fracturé de de de de ce
sentiment d'éloignement entre les
institutions et ces territoires
d'éloignement entre le réel et les
décisions qui se prennent à Paris donc
tout ça il faut y répondre on y répondra
pas en étant simplement des comptables
qui veulent succéder à d'autres
comptables il faut une gauche qui soit
claire ferme mais justement quand vous
regardez le message électoral qui avait
été envoyé il y a un an à la
présidentielle au dernières législativ
est-ce que le centre de gravité de la
gauche il ne s'est pas euh décalé vers
plus de radicalité qui est demandé par
les électeurs de gauche est-ce que vous
vous en convenez je redis Jean-Luc
Mélenchon a fait 22 % il a raté deux
fois la marche du 2è tour il ne se pose
jamais la question de savoir pourquoi
mais simplement parce que quand la
radicalité exclut à ce point une partie
des Français tout le centre gauche
toutes ces femmes et hommes attachés à
la République laïque toutes ces femmes
et hommes qui sont vicéralement fondé
sur les que le débat démocratique ne
peut pas verser dans la violence quand
on se coupe de cette frange électorale
systématiquement et bien on ne gagne
jamais et quand on a l'occasion de faire
l'union de la gauche comme il avait
l'occasion de la faire et que il aurait
pu lui qui cite en permanence François
mitteran se hisser au-dessus et dire je
rassemble et qu'il considère que dans ce
moment-là son son son sa stratégie c'est
uniquement de dire je vais soumettre à
ma plateforme politique à ma seule vue
politique à l'extrémisme de ma vision
politique tous les autres et bien vous
ratez une fois de plus ça marche et vous
excluez toute chance que la gauche
gouverne un jour en France et ça c'est
impardonnable et donc selon vous c'est
un homme comme Bernard casenuve qui est
plutôt de centre gauche avec son
mouvement de la convention qui peut
incarner cette nouvelle union de la
gauche moi je crois que l'avenir à
gauche c'est à la fois la capacité de
promettre aux françaises et aux Français
d'être protégé et leur promettre en même
temps une transformation sociale
profonde c'estàdire que il faut
promettre que nous ferons les
révolutions dans un cadre qui protège
chacune et chacun d'entre nous pas dans
un cadre qui soit le chaos comme le
propose etfi alors guume ro vous avez
participé aux dernières rencontrre de
Saint-Denis entre les chefs de partis
politiques et le président de la
République la dernière en date c'était
il y a 10 jours on n pas l'impression vu
l'état du pays que ces échanges ont créé
une forme de concorde d'unité nationale
ils étaient vraiment utiles vous ne
pouvez pas avir la concorde nationale
quand vous mettez dans la même table le
Front National et le Parti radical de
gauche faut dire les choses comme elles
sont on est quand même pas ce point
d'oubli de nos valeurs les uns et les
autres donc je crois pas que l'objet
c'était la concorde nationale ensuite
est-ce que c'est utile
se parler du pays avec le président de
la République et les chefs de partis qui
sont malgré tout les garants de la
parole publique qui V ensuite être tenu
pour essayer de maintenir la paix civile
ça n'est jamais inutile ensuite ça a
quand même permis d'évacuer les la
volonté
afficher d'élargir le cadre du
référendum pour en faire une espèce de
votation suisse permanente sur des
sujets dissociétaux qui allaient selon
Monsieur chotti Nous emmené jusque à un
référendum sur l'immigration dont on ne
voit pas bien ce qu'on aurait posé comme
question euh ça a au moins permis
d'évacuer cela ça a aussi permis de
rappeler queon allait pas encore
reporter le projet de loi sur la fin de
vie en attendant une éventuelle réforme
de la Constitution qui permettrait de
passer par voie référendaire donc moi je
ne considère pas que c'est inutile après
ceux qui attendent que ça remplace le
Conseil des ministres et le Parlement en
même temps effectivement ils sont déçus
mais enfin ce serait grave que ce soit
le cas parce que ça voudrait dire qu'on
ne respecterait pas notre démocratie
vous avez pu lors de ces rencontres
approché le président de la République
échanger avec lui en direct euh comment
avez-vous trouvé que vous êtes-il
inspiré
écoutez moi c'était ma première
participation puisque le le Parti
radical de gauche intégrait cette
réunion du fait de la présidence du
groupe RDSE au Sénat présidence assuré
par maris carer
aujourd'hui moi j'ai trouvé un président
de la République très casche très clair
notamment sur les enjeux de la situation
internationale fidèle à son style je
vous parle franchement ou en tout cas je
vous donne cette impression j'ai trouvé
un président de la République qui
voulait entendre chacun aussi qui a pris
le temps on a quand même alors certes
moins de temps que les premières
réunions mais on a quand même passé 9h3
avec lui dans la même pièce il a
souhaité que chacun s'exprime quand il
le souhaitait et autant qu'il le voulait
et il a répondu aux uns et aux autres
alors ensuite quen fait-il c'est ça la
grande question que se posent les
français Emmanuel Macron est capable de
dire des choses directes il est capable
d'écouter il est aussi capable de
beaucoup parler mais qu'en fait-il de ce
qu'il entend c'est ça le vrai point
d'interrogation de Saint- quen fera-t-il
alors en tout cas il ferme la porte à un
référendum sur le sujet de l'immigration
qui était demandé par la droite et par
l'extrême droite vous vous étiez contre
on vient de l'entendre cette idée de
référendum sur l'immigration pourquoi
les Français n'auraient pas le droit de
se prononcer sur ce sujet mais c'est pas
que les Français n'ont pas le droit de
se prononcer les Français ils élisent
des représentants ils élisent des
députés ces représentants portent un
projet politique une voix politique des
sensibilités politiques ces députés sont
habilités à voter vous voulez faire un
référendum sur l'immigration vous votez
sur quoi voulez-vous de l'immigration
oui ou non mais c'est c'est pas une
question enfin on sait tous
qu'aujourd'hui dans notre pays beaucoup
d' industrie repose en partie sur le
fait que notre territoire accueille des
gens venus d'ailleurs et qui viennent
travailler et on sait tous aujourd'hui
j'entendais le ministre de l'Industrie
dire qu'on aurait besoin de 100 à 200000
personnes suppl laroix de
l'affaiblissement du Parlement moi j'ai
peur de l'affaiblissement de la
représentativité vous savez un de mes
grands désaccords avec Emmanuel Macron
c'est cette idée qu'il faut un un lien
direct entre Jupiter et et et le peuple
c'est extrêmement dangereux surtout dans
un moment comme celui que nous
traversons nous avons besoin c'est du
populisme c'est du populisme pour vous
c'est une forme de démocratie qui se
veut soi-disant direct et qui ne l'est
pas du tout parce que on voit que chaque
fois Jupiter fait absolument ce qu'il
veut et puis parce que c'est dangereux
parce que dans ce moment d'immense
tenstion il faut des corps
intermédiaires pour pondérer il faut des
gens en proximité pour parler je pense à
ces élus locaux je pense évidemment à
tous les maires je pense à tous les élus
locaux mais je pense aussi au syndicats
je pense à tous les corps intermédiaires
à tous ces groupes d'intérêts qui se
réunissent et qui parlent parce que
quand ça va mal il faut parler il faut
entendre la voix à tous les échelons et
qu'ensuite cette voix soit représentée
quand vous êtes dans un lien direct
quand vous êtes dans une votation
citoyenne permanente vous êtes dans
l'émotion et dans ce moment-là l'émotion
on sait ce qu'ell nous dicte quand je
vois la mort de Thomas je suis en colère
quand je vois la mort de Thomas je suis
en colère mais je suis un responsable
politique et donc mon devoir c'est de
transformer ma colère en un projet
politique qui soit raisonné et
raisonnable c'est ça aujourd'hui être un
républicain dans ce pays alors cette
semaine le projet de loi immigration
arrive à l'Assemblée national il va être
examiné par la commission des lois de
l'Assemblée est-ce que pour vous c'est
un texte qui va être utile au pays il y
a besoin dans ce pays de traiter de la
question de l'immigration ça n'est pas
un sujet il y a un besoin de traiter à
la fois de l'asile aussi enfin de
renforcer de réaffirmer que la demande
d'asile en France et en Europe mais donc
en France est un droit historique
fondamental que nous sommes là pour
protéger celles et ceux qui souffrent
que dirait-on si notre pays n'avait pas
été là à la réponse pour l'Afghanistan
là à la réponse pour l'Ukraine même si
on n'est pas dans le CRE de l'asile là à
la réponse pour les Iraniennes ou les
Iraniens qui fut le régime enfin c'est
quand même notre devoir moral historique
fraternel que d'être là donc sur l'asile
et puis sur l'immigration évidemment
qu'il y a un sujet on sait bien que
notre pays fait partie de ces pays comme
beaucoup de pays européens attractif
quand on est dans une fuite d'une misère
économique et qu'on cherche finalement
un endroit où l'on pense que l'on va
pouvoir se sentir mieux la démarche de
migrer économiquement elle est pas
nouvelle elle est historiques toutes les
femmes et tous les hommes du monde ont
toujours bougé et chercher à aller vers
des des terres qui étaient des terres
qui leur paraissaient plus accueillantes
pour autant nous ne pouvons pas être
dans une situation où nous laissons
entrer tout le monde dans ce pays on ne
peut pas considérer que tout tout se
fasse dans une situation désorganisée
moi je suis très prenez quand même de la
fermeté il faut de la fermeté mais pas
la dérive que on a observé au Sénat sur
ce texte où on en arrive à mettre même
les Français en danger au nom d'une
forme de dogmatisme antiimmigration en
supprimant laame quand on supprime la me
l'aide médicale d'État et qu'on met en
danger l'ensemble des Français d'un
risque de pandémie franchement est-ce
que cette espèce de jusqu'au buisme pour
courir derrière l'extrême droite a
j'allais dire fait oublier au sénateurs
leur devoir de protéger tous les
Français la mesure far c'est la
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papierers dans les métiers en tension au
départ dans le taex initial c'était une
régularisation de plein droit le Sénat a
modifié le texte pour en faire une
régularisation au cas par cas selon le
pouvoir discrétionnaire du préfet vous
quel est votre quelle est la version qui
vous convient la version qui me convient
c'est d'abord une version dans laquelle
le gouvernement n'a qu'une parole je
suis quand même un peu surpris de ce qui
s'est passé au Sénat avec Monsieur
Darmanin qui laisse voter les sénateurs
librement en disant sagesse du du Sénat
sur ces questionsl où les sénateurs de
renaissance viennent prêter main forte à
Monsieur rotaillo je m'interroge quand
même sur les dérives politiques des uns
et des autres je je vous le dis aussi
notre pays compte et c'est sa richesse
de nombreux migrants qui sont
parfaitement intégrés travaillent sont
des gens et des femmes honnêtes bien sûr
qu'il y a une frange parmi eux qui sont
des gens qui mettent en danger notre
sécurité il s'agit pas de le nier mais
ça n'est pas la majorité il faut être
clairement vigilant et ferme vis-à-vis
de celles et ceux qui créent le trouble
mais pour celles et ceux qui se sont
intégrés qui sont des modèles
d'intégration qui travaillent qui
servent nos industries qui permettent la
création de richesse et la
redistribution de richesse mais enfin on
leur doit cette cette régularisation
Guillaume Lacroix dernière question sur
la fin de vie et le projet de loi qui
sera présenté par le gouvernement il y
aura une mesure d'aide active à mourir
qu'est-ce que demandent les Radicaux de
Gauche est-ce qu'il demandent clairement
la légalisation de l'euthanasie nous
demandons la légalisation de
l'aideactive à mourir de l'aideactive à
mourir pas de référendum non plus non
mais le référendum al je ve dire ça
c'est typiquement le genre de question
effectivement qui aurait pu être porté
par un référendum sauf qu'aujourd'hui ça
n'est pas possible et que il faudrait
encore attendre les calandes Grecs pour
qu'on y arrive aujourd'hui on sait que
l'opinion publique est très largement
majoritaire au fait que dans ce pays il
y ait véritablement une capacité de s'en
aller dans la dignité quand on considère
que on ne peut plus j'allais dire
survivre à une pathologie à une maladie
et qu'on ne veut pas se voir dépérir de
façon indécente oui aujourd'hui des
concitoyens à nous vont en Suisse vont
en Belgique pour des sommes folles dans
des cadres incroyables pour pouvoir
mourir comme il le souhaitent c'est un
devoir d'humanité que nous avons et donc
oui moi je suis mon parti évidemment
depuis très longtemps pour l'euthanasie
clairement il l'a toujours dit
aujourd'hui il faut faire progresser la
loi il faut que nous soyons
véritablementan
mais il faut les deux deux piliers dans
une j'allais dire dans une loi bien
pensée il faut améliorer encore les
soins palliatifs et les pousser plus
loin mais il faut aussi laisser la
possibilité à celles et ceux qui le
souhaitent et on décide librement de
mettre un terme à leur vie merci
beaucoup Guillaume Lacroix d'avoir été
notre invité politique ce matin